j'ai l'habitude de prendre chaque année
maman gaza mais cette fois j'ai
m'inquiète peut-être que j'aurais pas
mon visa
[Musique]
et c'est une décision qui est nécessaire
qui est rendu nécessaire par le fait que
ces pays n'acceptent pas de reprendre
des ressortissants que nous ne
souhaitons pas et que nous ne pouvons
pas garder en france
[Musique]
il ya eu le premier ministre qui s'est
rendu sur place dans les pays concernés
les membres du gouvernement aussi gérald
darmanin qui s'est rendu sur place il ya
eu des réunions avec les ambassadeurs
des pays concernés à un moment quand les
choses ne bougent pas oui nous faisons
appliquer les règles
[Musique]
donc
le trailer comme
la requête à laquelle
raymond l'homme ménagement la berline
voulez mais je me fais fort normal
[Musique]